[Music]
[Applause]
Tom Kern Patriots Insider NBC Sports
Boston
was the plan to play two quarterbacks
last night Tom Kerr yes yes I fully
believe that was the plan and that Bill
Belichick and Mac Jones definitely were
the two who were most in accord on that
then
okay tell me why they would play two
quarterbacks
I believe
that bill wanted to get the rust knocked
off of Mac Jones see how he performed as
he came back from his four-week layoff
and if he performed well leave him out
there but his intention I think was to
get Bailey's happy in there as well
because he didn't believe that Mac was
100 which is uncharacteristic for Bill
to do but when I read Mike florio's
reporting on it
saying that Mac really pushed hard to
play and Belichick eventually yielded to
that leads me to believe that this was
less about a punitive benching for the
horrific interception and more about you
know what he's not really ready let's
get him out now
yeah I wondered if it was going to take
game action for him to realize that Mac
Jones should have been out there that
that was what surprised me and you know
it's National TV if this is a one
o'clock game on Sunday it's not as big a
deal but it's a big deal because it's a
stand-alone game you're supposed to beat
the Bears and do you have a quarterback
controversy yeah it's a big deal too
because
for the better part of three games
Bailey's happy had come in and performed
in a way that Mac Jones had Patriots are
now two and seven in Mac Jones last nine
starts
it's good I believe it's 10 uh
touchdowns and 11 picks and Bailey's
happy the team is 2-0 with him under
Center
so for him to be serenaded Mac Jones by
booze as he's leaving the field and to
hear an uproar for a fourth round pick
from Western Kentucky who has been a
nice story when playing from ahead but
he ain't ready
it's turned into a spectacle that seemed
necessary and Dan it's to me I mean we
you know Bill we've been covering the
NFL both of us for decades
it seems so uncharacteristic but I
really do believe that he was appeasing
Mac Jones request and pressuring him to
play and said okay we'll get you out
there we'll play you some but Bailey's
going to come in Ross Tucker who played
for the Patriots uh back in uh well 15
years ago he said that Belichick loves
to have you uncomfortable but I don't
want you uncomfortable at the
quarterbacking position as a defensive
back or defensive lineman or offensive
lineman okay I I don't want you to
settle in and you know take things for
granted uh I got two quarterbacks who
probably don't know where they stand
right now yeah neither one is coming off
what we would call high at the moment
what's confusing about it is Belichick
invited this by doing this and you know
he's usually got things so buttoned up
so was it also a case of taking the
Bears a little bit lightly which again
would be an uncharacteristic decision
and it also invites because you can't
treat it like defensive tackle
it invites
factions in the locker room Bailey guy
Matt guy in my experience in that locker
room talking to the players listening to
Belichick in July talking about Max
dramatic Improvement and how he was
drastically better than last year and he
was really good
there isn't a quarterback controversy
regardless of what we're watching unfold
I believe the Patriots believe Mac Jones
is their quarterback of the future until
he proves otherwise which he might be on
his way to doing but
it's not a quarterback controversy they
want Matt Jones to succeed
talking to Tom Curran the Patriots
Insider NBC Sports Boston how do you
think this plays out okay who's starting
against the Jets in your opinion
Mac Jones I you know and I say that with
resignation because I wrote for two
weeks well once Max ready to go you just
sail with him through the end of the
year and it took all the three seriously
for that to be incorrect then but I will
believe it will be Mac Jones
and you ride with the guy
is this still a playoff team
they're going to nose around the cusp of
the uh threshold of the brink of it I
had him as an 8-9 team and they didn't
gender a lot of optimism in the last
three weeks performance in Green Bay win
over Detroit and went over uh Cleveland
both in you know convincing fashion but
then these nights happen and you get
blown out by probably the 30th best team
in the league at home and you start to
look back and go was that real
what the Lions really stink you know the
Packer's kind of crappy and maybe the
Browns also stink and maybe they stink
too so it's that little we go like this
if I put this to a vote with the fans
who would they pick
as of 10 o'clock last night
Dr zappy
uh this morning I think our little guy
turned into a pumpkin
it's back to Mac until further notice I
would think but that's what Twitter is
for and I will be sending out a poll
shot me okay great to talk to you as
always you're a good guy thank you Tom
okay Tom E Curran Patriots Insider